even though james bond films are
espionage action flicks they also
contain a fair amount of humor to add a
dash of comedic fun and to soften the
blow of some rather violent scenes
especially death scenes from the
hilarious to the macabre here obon's
best post post-kill one-liners
in tomorrow never dies piers brosnan
drops an absolutely fantastic one-liner
that cracks us up right after a
particularly nasty kill at this point in
the film a bund is in a massive facility
that contains a printing press that
looks like it generates 100 newspapers
per second reams of paper are weaving in
and out of a complex system of machinery
and the sound is deafening and it's here
that brosnan goes toe-to-toe with a
henchman and you can probably guess
where the bad guy ends up by the fight's
end that's right directly into the
printing press as with so many of our
deaths listed here the site is pretty
gruesome the body jams up the printing
press and the newspaper flying through
the machinery is stained red from the
victim's blood bond looks at a pile of
newspapers hot off the press and says
don't print anything these days
including a criminal henchman literally
in sean connery's very first double 07
film dr no we find bond innocently
driving his car in a winding dirt road
when suddenly he notices he's being
followed the car behind bond is
aggressively chasing him even tapping
his rear bumper a few times bond tries
to lose these bad guys by driving
extremely fast around turns hoping the
villain will fail to keep up at those
speeds it's quite a dangerous game to
play since one side of the road is a
cliff that looks at least a couple of
stories high bond fails to lose him at
first but to his luck there's a
construction vehicle in the middle of
the road doing who knows what
conveniently bond's car is small enough
to drive through a small opening but the
henchmen in the car behind barnes can't
make it at the last second the villains
try grinding to a halt but they drive
off the edge and their car rolls down
the mountain exploding in the process as
a clueless bystander the construction
worker is completely bewildered
wondering what happened ever ready with
a quip bond says i think they were on
the way to a funeral
honestly it's pretty brilliant after all
the construction worker probably took it
to mean that the henchmen were in a rush
to get to a funeral but bundles implying
the henchmen were on their way to their
own funerals
this one-liner comes from the fan
favorite film goldfinger in the
pre-credit scene bond accomplishes his
mission by blowing up a drug laboratory
he's then warned by an ally that the
drug lords will seek revenge and that he
should leave immediately but that just
isn't the bond way before the spy hops
on a plane home he must first sleep with
a woman that he's been courting but
little does bond know that she plans to
kill him she hides a hitman in her
apartment welcomes bond in and then does
something very clever she casually
mentions that bum's gun makes her
uncomfortable prompting the agent to
take it off his person she kisses bonds
while the henchman sneaks up but double
07 catches a reflection of the would-be
attacker in her eye no really he does
that's how eyes work he dodges the first
attack but from that point on the two
engage in a rather equal wrestling match
in the hotel room it culminates with
bond throwing the henchman into a full
bathtub and while the bad guy gets a
hold of bond's gun double 007 thinks
fast and smacks an electric fan into the
water electrocuting the villain to death
that's when bond says shocking
positively shocking
but was he saying these words about the
woman who betrayed him what was he
saying them about how his victim
perished from his glances it looks like
both
to fully appreciate this one liner you
have to understand something about the
main villain of from russia with love
the major baddie in this 1963 action
flick is rosa cleb a former russian
counter-intelligence up who joins the
mysterious organization spectre as
number three while cleb has similarities
with other bond villains she does have a
rather unique weapon shoes that conceal
poison tipped blades when you least
expect it club ejects one of these
blades from her shoes and starts kicking
at you a single cut can land you in the
hospital at the end of the film bond is
relaxing in a hotel room with bond girl
tatiana romanova meanwhile cleb
disguised as a maid is trying one last
time to eliminate bonds and retrieve a
valuable known as elector fortunately
bond and romanov win a fight with cleb
in the hotel room which ends with
romanover shooting kleppe dead afterward
romanov remarks that she was a quote
horrible woman
she's had her kicks
it's a clever little jab at her killer
sense of fashion
james bond delivered this little quip
after defeating one of the most
difficult baddies in the entire double
07 franchise odd job hailing from the
movie goldfinger our job is a short but
extremely formidable opponent working
for the main villain oreck goldfinger at
this point in the film odd job and bond
are fighting each other inside fort knox
and it's epic bond holds a heavy gold
blockade job but it just bounces off his
chest then bon tries jumping on our job
and tackling him but odd job picks up
double 07 and tosses him like he's a
frisbee the spider attempts punching his
foe whacking him with a stick and
throwing a metal ringed hat all of which
fail clearly bond has no choice with the
thing outside of the box and that's
exactly what he does at one point our
job goes to retrieve his metal hat which
is lodged between metal bars at the same
moment our job touches his bowler bond
puts an open wire under the bus
electrocuting our job to death later on
cia agent felix lighter as where his
butler friend was and bond replies
oh he blew a fuse
quite literally we might add
it should go without saying but one of
the major elements of goldfinger is gold
the main villain is named orrick
goldfinger with the first two letters of
his first name representing gold in the
periodic table at one point the bad guy
kills a woman and paints her whole body
in gold because why not and of course
goldfinger loves gold so much that he
dedicates his entire criminal career to
smuggling it and even gathers a small
militia to rob fort knox as a result
it's only fitting that goldfinger would
have a golden end during the climax of
the film bond fights goldfinger on a
plane which culminates in goldfinger
getting sucked out a window a little bit
later [ __ ] galore yes that's her name
asks bond what happened to goldfinger
bond spills the news that goldfinger is
dead but he does so with the clever
one-liner playing his golden heart yeah
we've got to admit it's a golden line
in thunderball our suave spy gets one of
the smoothest kills in w7 history bond
is going up against emilio lago a
villain who stole nuclear weapons and is
threatening to use them to help locate
them bond is attempting to recruit
domino who's largo's mistress bond and
domino have a rather heartfelt and
serious conversation on a beach where
bond explains to domino that largo
killed her brother and may soon kill
millions after she agrees to help bond
begins instructing her on how to use
some gadgets to get the job done but
that's when one of largo's henchmen
starts sneaking up on them domino called
as a cucumber casually tells bun that
the henchman is right behind him and
bond equally as cool says quote really
in the flash of a second bond picks up a
speed again turns around and shoots the
henchman with the kill accomplished bond
remarks
i think he got the point that's what you
get for trying to sneak up on james bond
while james bond's post kill one-liners
are generally one and done this
particular comment has been used in two
separate films in you only live twice
the evil blofeld has an elaborate
volcano lair equipped with a pool of
flesh-eating piranhas that he uses for
executions at one point blofeld is
scalding an underling named helga brand
for failing to kill bond as punishment
blofeld mercilessly activates the trap
door that drops brandt into the piranha
tank she's eaten alive in seconds which
is blofeld's way of showing everyone
watching that he doesn't tolerate
failure anyway the moral of the story is
you don't want to fall into this water
well later on bond gets into a brawl
with hans one of blofeld's strongest
henchmen after going back and forth a
bit bond finally manages to throw hans
into the ball of piranhas which promptly
ends his life bond encouraged the fish
to eat saying simply
but this quip also appears in license to
kill when bond breaks into an aquarium
at night to located in drugs he
discovers an incubator full of maggots
which are fed to fish right then a
henchman finds him but bond uses some
kung fu to throw the body into the bed
of maggots and then shuts the draw
bon appetit
disgusting
this one liner is a bit more gruesome
for bond films than we're typically used
to it comes from on her majesty's secret
service delivered by one george lazenby
leading up to the line bond is skiing
down a mountain with teresa tracy draco
and chasing after them is a group of
henchmen who are also on skis it's quite
an exciting sequence involving bad guys
using machine guns an epic ski chase and
an avalanche but the craziest part of
the chase is when everyone skies past
this huge snowblowing machine one sorry
henchman falls into the contraption
which has massive sharp gears that eat
up snow before shooting it out after
getting caught in that monstrosity the
snowblower shoots out red snow yikes and
that's when bondi yells over to tracy
saying he had lots of guts
it works both figuratively and that the
henchman was brave enough to chase after
james bond and also quite literally not
that we need to explain that
ever see an injury on screen so painful
that you feel it even as a viewer that's
what you'll feel watching this death
sequence in diamonds are forever a pair
of assassins named mr win to mr kid a
hunting bond in the service of blofeld
the evil duo find our hero on a boat and
they attempt to kill him by bringing a
small bomber board bond quickly
dispenses with mr kidd but it's the
second villain we're interested in mr
wint as mr wins and bond fight back and
forth a double 07 gets the upper hand by
yanking mr wins arms through his legs
and upwards it's obviously painful given
the sound he makes while bond has him in
this terribly uncomfortable position he
attaches the bomb to mr wind and throws
him overboard after the bad guy explodes
bon says well he certainly left with his
tails between his legs yeah double 07
would never let a bad guy die with
dignity
live and let die might just feature the
most creative death in the entire james
bond franchise and that's really saying
something the bizarre kill happens at
the climax when the main villain dr
kaninga captures 007 and the new bond
girl solitaire like all bond villains dr
kanenga must execute bond in an
elaborate way which naturally gives bond
the opportunity to escape this time the
villain will try to kill bond and his
girl by slowly lowering them into a pool
of sharks but double seven escapes by
using his gadget watch to soar through
the rope and then he starts fighting
kaninga the battle becomes a lot more
suspenseful when the two fall into the
shark infested water but it may surprise
you to know that the sharks never kill
either one of them instead while in the
water bond takes a gas compressed pellet
and forces dr kaninga to swallow it the
result dr kaninga inflates the several
times to size floats to the ceiling and
explodes
talk about a wild death bond's only
remarquez he always did have an inflated
opinion of himself
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]